citizens of the reject nation we're
gonna watch cobra kai season five
episode four today
andrew heydon i'm doing great craig how
are you great
john crate
great
great andrew rossi shirts so would that
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated leave a like for your
favorite shirt subscribe and click the
notification bell to get notified when a
reaction for the next episode of cobra
kai is up with benjen and also fully
interaction watch long is where you sync
up with the time code for cobra copying
your own copy available for super sexy
rejects at our patreon page where we
cover several shows of reaction
highlights and watch long's included
exclusively covered over there for some
shows and the team of prepper thank you
for helping settle these down let's get
to it
[Music]
hey johnny um could you help me with
something
here to help
i'm here for whatever you need
[Music]
hey
yes
[Music]
i couldn't have chosen to do this at a
more perfect year having any fun yet
that's why he's got his mustache look
like goose that was rooster
should have worn my top gun shirt but
this is better andrew
[Music]
wait did we just time jump no it's a
dream it's his fantasy
damn
enjoying it her fantasy but she did say
she loved top gun in one of the earlier
seasons there's your resume
yeah
you tell me all about it was i maverick
from top gun
did we go to the danger zone amanda and
i are heading to a charity auction she's
looking to get more involved who knows
maybe even a spot on the board
keep an eye on the dealership and the
house just be ready for anything
dude that shirt has so many pockets do
you have robbie's stuff for me
yeah
sure he's gonna be all right spending
the summer at my parents cabin on
bainbridge island beach is hiking three
meals a day yeah he's gonna be just fine
did he book another movie or something
it actually looks like a functioning
adult lives here now ah made some
changes
that is a real lighthouse and near a
gansett built in 1856.
who are you oh my god
you knocked carmen up didn't you ah
never thought i'd see the day
where is this
raging waters home of the excellent
water slides i understood that reference
i've never been to raging waters you're
missing out man
how's the whole eat pray love journey
going it's actually been better than i
expected
it's been kind of nice to just
focus on myself
miguel and i are still friends hey
what's up
hi
um
hey hey how you doing
hey tori
we'll see you later they're always in
the same place at the same time i know
it's perfect
it's perfect it wasn't really that kind
of trip but uh we did work out a few of
our issues
there's still some that are just too big
to solve
splash off
cannonball
now's the time to get out before things
get worse
i can't just quit well if i did it you
can do it
trust me silver's gonna get inside of
your head and then he's gonna tell you
that i'm glad you and your dad work
through some of your [ __ ] but don't tell
me what to do i'm a big girl i can make
my own decisions sometimes a man needs
to guide a woman though
robbie's not out he was just on a trip
hey you tripping if you think he's
coming back
dude is out like flynn okay we out here
on our own bro
hey let's go to the big boy rocks the
lifeguard
oh he sees anthony
yeah we'll drown him
strike first
thank you
he's got like a dumb and dumber outfit
on
where's her orange suit amanda's been
gushing about your organization helping
on the privileged teens is very
important to her to both of us well then
we share that in common your house is so
beautiful oh this isn't my home uh it
belongs to one of our donors
he's angling for a spot on the board
yep
yep yep whatever you're up to you leave
my family out of it
you do not
ruin this day for my wife
i have no intention of ruining her day
let's just hope nothing else ruins it
for her
i said i was sorry okay and you already
got me back you know i
thought we were cool oh oh you thought
we were cool okay let me think um
[Music]
whoa did he hit his head on that
maybe he needs another haircut to
remember who he's talking to do you want
to take on the champ kid
dude you're only the champ because diaz
got hurt probably won as many fights as
you d yeah but one of those is against
you that wasn't much of a fight now was
it
oh damn
all right
you guys stay on your side we don't have
a problem
we have better rides on our side anyway
hey it's over he's not worth it but they
do it better right
we gotta get those rights it's a 2013
obear from my private collection
still a little young but
much more complex than what they're
serving at the park you don't want to
sleep with them at all
come on just a little bit let's get back
at daniel for all the travis
that's terry's long game what i want is
to train kids to use karate not for war
but to better themselves and
i wish daniel would see that instead of
sending his man to rough up my potential
hires oh god
he's so smart
what are you guys named michael it's
michaela whatever huh
hurry up there's other apps telling me i
got to pick up a guy named jimmy john
huh
five stars for johnny
can can you play some billy eilish tells
ya billy idol
[Music]
morgan we are golden i'm telling you
wait what
can you turn down the music i'm in the
middle of a deal here hey shut the hell
up this is the best part
you should probably get in the left lane
are you gonna turn on your signal hey
watch out for that car
[Applause]
oh
get up
out
huh oh god no
it's stressing me out so much workers
ice cold now the windows were down okay
well i can't eat a cold burger sure you
can done it a ton of times
hey don't forget to leave a five-star
review
no huh dumb and dumber
what are you doing up there are you
oprah kai's claimed it
so
we're just gonna let them make up
arbitrary rules
we have just as much right to those
slides as anyone else
bad ass girl you tell them devin lee
god
you need to do your best johnny lawrence
quiet and there's keith i thought you
said it wasn't in kubrick anymore that's
what sensei told me
come on
victim of misunderstandings
yes
don't get mike barnes
okay clearly we can't co-exist in peace
so let's find a solution
we can't fight we'll be kicked out so
what are we supposed to do
we need to go no how about a race
i like it
splash off
yeah i'll go
so alive all right champer's champ
whoever wins gets the park the park is
terry silver gonna pay so she wins again
i think you didn't tell me some chosen
to assault numerous job applicants at
silver's dojo what
what i did not send him in to do that he
was put in a bad situation believe me
calling him job applicants is generous
hey up next
[Laughter]
goblin
[Applause]
that's a racist delivery
hey it was an impression of mr miyagi
thank you though greg that's what my
mentor taught me many years ago he not
only brought these trees into my life
but what they represent
and i am honored to pass on his legacy
and these beautiful trees to a lucky
person here today terry
twenty dollars
going for three thousand
thirty five hundred
four thousand
five thousand thirty thousand dollars
my my
unless there are any objections
sold to the generous mr silver
oh
giving back to underprivileged youth has
always been a passion of mine and it is
entirely
as a joint initiative with dreams for
teens
i will be offering free karate classes
to all low-income students at any one of
our dojo
you better respect these bonsais
they do sound like a lot of work
might just use a bulge
oh
i want all that money
here
think of keto
it'll make you feel better i already
took one and it didn't know
you know not everybody gets to do their
dream job most people hate what they do
you think i ever wanted to work in a
pawn shop let alone own three
dealing with the likes of you is like
the worst part of my day
but most of all it allows me time for
what matters most
my family hmm
maybe you're not such an [ __ ] after
all
oh
still giving you one star for touching
my food join the club man he just became
human
dude that guy's gonna be a huge
character in season six i know you're in
kobukai because of me but i just wanted
you there because i thought it would
help you
it did it'll turn you into someone you
don't want to be
that's what happened to me are you
fighting your friend
or your opponent
[Applause]
martin cove gets a paycheck
ah nah i'm glad you didn't hold back i
needed that no kenny i have been down
this path for back off
now i'm stronger than i've ever been
i'll never quit
because i'm not a quitter
[Applause]
who are these people watching
they're at the mercy of the lazy river
good thing there's no other people going
on the ride yeah
[Music]
how much control do they have over this
race i know
[Applause]
what are you gonna do about it
am i gonna strike first if that's what
you think
you know that balls to anyone
[Applause]
damn is that all you got
[Applause]
watch yourself you want to go
hey
everybody get out and leave the park
immediately
i mean it everybody out now
karate ruins lives
let's go anthony
all because of anthony about amanda
thanks for telling me of course i'm glad
we could chat
what
you snake i told her she's a phony
psychopathic liar
who should never be trusted
oh no look at him just acting like he's
so much great i just said all these lies
about my wife so ms garcia
actually he spoke quite highly of amanda
he did what he told me how respected
your wife is in the community how your
whole family is
thank you
oh that hurts damn
[ __ ]
master manipulator amanda wait
no one sees him smiling
at least say he told you that i want him
to come stay with me this summer all
right i'll do whatever i have to make it
work
i quit too many jobs over the years
because i didn't like them instead of
considering what's best for all of us
i'm sorry i suck shannon
i was actually about to go pick him up
from the water park but if you want to
go tell him the news
hell yeah hey johnny
i'm happy for you
thanks
did you just miss my stop oh it's that
guy i know you won the tournament
everything's going good for you right
now but by defending them you're part of
the problem no i was just hoping that we
could have a fun day together
but i guess that's impossible it's only
impossible if you're still in copper guy
so staying with me
ooh
i could have sworn since i said you ride
a cobra kai i'm not in cobra cotton that
you're on their side every time they
start fighting you don't know what the
hell you're talking about look i know
you think just because you came down to
mexico that you think you're a good guy
will guess what you're not we'll look
who's talking uh-oh i can't come down to
mexico for you we already asked you to
go anywhere hey hey damn miguel you're
getting so aggressive we're all friends
now no
we're not friends we never will be
ugh
shedding i don't want robin to stay
it's gonna be awkward
i think you should stay at mcgill's
i'm afraid we're never gonna have
normalcy ever again not when you
continue to stir up these ridiculous
fights fight that furniture storm my
fault not his
please blame me
you had a fight at a furniture store
enough is enough daniel this ends now
this is exactly what silva wanted to
happen he manipulated this whole thing
to get us to fight do you hear yourself
you really won't stop you need to let me
and chosen handle this ooh
fine
handle it but i won't be here for it
where are you going away from here away
from you it just needs space
taking the kids with
oh that'd be good for sam's mental
health would be very good
[Music]
damn dang
john
man
things are getting crazy at the
valley
in the valley of los angeles nah man i
mean this
just keeps on going this is a really
great binge because yeah it just keeps
on building and as we've gotten deeper
into the season i've started to wonder
like okay
we're off to a really great start i'm
loving where we're headed and how are
they gonna you know just maintain this
over ten or however many episodes and i
like the ways in which they have it be
kind of about the argument it's like
yeah the formations of the dojos and
those rivalries still exist
but it's more about yeah how that
affects everybody outside of the context
in just normal life and how do we
co-exist and how do we settle these
differences after we've already been
past the phase of we could just fight it
out because clearly we can't do that
um so yeah i like the kind of physical
side of the episode you had with all the
you know the everybody at the water park
and then just this horrible mind game
of danny and and terry terry silver and
i like that they draw it well enough
that you can tell that danny's right but
you can also tell that amanda's right
it's like if danny had just not taken
every line of bait that terry put out
there
and if he had stepped back and breathed
enough to know like no he's he's
targeting me and he's gonna use
smarter tactics than just pettiness to
do it and yeah i think they've drawn it
really nicely thus far and hey you know
johnny's uh
learning the value of of uh working for
other folks instead of just himself so
that's nice too
what did you guys think i thought johnny
is an amazing
or ride share driver and he really does
a good job delivering food and to people
on time because
yeah what was as your expert opinion
what would you say yeah i mean he's
great i would want him i'd want to ride
in a car with him and want him to
deliver my food for sure although i
usually cook my meals but that's just me
uh getting into this episode i love
seeing thomas ian griffith the way he
manipulates the character of terry
silver that's why he's my favorite i
love him so much
i i mean like you said you know you got
you got a problem
i just think he's a hero he's my
favorite
it's just it's his performance his
bravado i just i love the way he
manipulates since karate kid part three
he's been
he always finds a way to get and dance
in daniel's head and i just it's just so
much fun to watch on screen even though
you shouldn't be cheering this on and i
mean
i'm not saying i'm cheering it on but
i'm just saying it's once a week you're
going to be here with a little ponytail
yeah
with some cocaine some pony mustaches no
i just i i just i love watching this
character and i love i mean again i
shouldn't be you know this into a
villain or a antagonist but i just love
the way he manipulates i love the way he
manipulates daniel it's so much fun to
watch on screen and then the way uh all
the relationships how they're handling
it on screen it's just it's done so
delicately it's done so well it's very
comp it shouldn't be but it's done so
com such in a compelling fashion and i
really enjoy it uh just seeing uh miguel
and samantha's relationship like every
time they start to get a little bit it
inches a little bit closer oh no it
breaks it riffs and then even miguel and
robbie they're starting to have a little
bit of understanding now it riffs and
breaks and then amanda and daniel nope
no terry's manipulating him it's just
the show just handles relationships and
character interactions they're matt the
writers and the creators are such
masters at handling relationships and
character interactions on the show
now we'll get to the easter egg and one
other thing before i get to the easter
eggs i i like that we hurry it up
i know in the first was this episode
four right and the first three episodes
we didn't really get to see much of the
other characters so it was nice to see
everyone come back to the forefront and
get you know get to see the ensemble
again and getting and getting the
storylines going again in regards to
those characters like with kenny and
anthony because that really was an
important storyline at least from my
perspective in season four with anthony
and kenny i didn't i wasn't sure how i
felt about it like when we were leading
into that storyline the uh the first
time we watched season four but
again while i don't want anthony i mean
i know most people are going to disagree
with me here while you don't want to see
kids get bullied because i was bullied
in middle school physically and uh
mentally it's not a fun thing although
anthony does i think we can all agree
anthony does deserve it after what he
did to kenny and you know the motivation
he drove him to joe and kobrakai and you
know what he did to him i understand
that but like seeing someone actually
get bullied it does suck even though i i
do hope they go the route which i'm sure
they will because the writers are so
brilliant of seeing anthony really have
some remorse this season i know he said
dude i apologize to you but it's like
dude come on that's like yeah you
apologize but like but i mean i want to
make it right i know i want to see i
really want to see like throughout the
season i want to see the acting range of
that actor and who plays anthony i want
to really see that remorse other than
saying i apologize you know and i want
to see where they go the depths they go
with that characters because that is an
interesting uh those two characters are
really intriguing to me uh so for the
easter eggs and references when we see
at the beginning of carmen's dream we
see the faucet break just like in karate
kid uh par at the first film karate kid
in 1984 we see the faucet was broken
that's where mr miyagi had to come in to
fix it we see uh carmen is having the
dream sequence and all of a sudden the
top gun uh
montage starts playing two things in
that the dream sequence uh johnny had a
dream sequence of him uh in season two
was either episode eight or nine uh
where he had a dream sequence about
carmen that uh showed that he's like
he's in madly in love with her
and uh in regards to top gun they had to
talk about top gun because i believe uh
i forgot which character said that they
went oh uh and now i remember it was in
season four
that carmen said that mr larusso showed
uh
uh miguel top gun and he said top gun he
showed him top gun he's like yeah and he
said that uh
uh tom cruise was amazing because tom
cruise is the worst it's iceman's the
best in that so there was our little
reference back to top gun in that
and then we got uh him peeing in the uh
in the beer can that's a reference to
dumb and dumber 1994 fairly brothers
movie i think you guys have heard of it
uh where lloyd christmas is peeing in
the uh in the car right before the cop
pulls them over and then we the last one
i can think of is uh johnny is now an
uber driver which is very interesting
because in one of the uh i think it was
at the end of season four in the last
episode where miguel uh leaves the the
karate tournament carmen says to johnny
oh he took an uber and johnny goes uber
what's then she goes it's it's like a
taxi it's like foreshadowing i thought
that was that interesting that now he's
an uber driver when she mentioned that
so that's all the ones i could think of
and then i guess you're one of uh
at uh the what was it the water park
from pill and ted i don't know if it's
actually no i know we're just gonna give
john his reference let me have this
moment
i'll take a reference
the bonsai trees
have been featured in other karate kids
ah i forgot that one mr miyagi thank you
john for the save those were the actual
ones probably
greg what do you got right easter eggs
references
no thought on the episode
subscribe to the channel i could give
you some more thoughts and you could
just say them out loud
it's
okay oh and one last thing i do want to
add not easter eggs are references i
really love the the performance but i
mean i love everyone's performance
there's no and no weaknesses and many of
the actors or actresses here i really
love uh robbie he's he's really grown on
me uh the last couple seasons i i mean
the first two seasons maybe it was this
haircut i don't know but i
this actor i mean uh tanner buchanan's
name i'm probably zola manamakaba that's
the one
he's really he's again i i love the
growth and the arc of this character so
far just understanding like cobra guy
was the wrong way and then he's trying
like he's seeing that his friends and
all his uh companions from cobra and his
girlfriend and kenny's protege like how
they're all going down the wrong path
and that really hurts him internally
internally and he's trying to like you
know make them see the better way
and i and i really like that and again i
just i love the way he emotes and his
acting process just he's a really good
actor and he's
in really good shape too
they wanted to make sure we saw that
that's a 15 year old boy you're talking
about he's older than that shut up i
could talk about his body i can talk
about it even though he's supposed to
play 15
we all know he's like 23. guys i'm in
i'm i'm trying to get in good shape here
okay i notice people in good shape i i
gotta give them their props okay
you're gonna be on the robbie diet
trying
yeah
that's true
all right guys
i'm over this show
terrible you don't like it
tear it apart
uh no it is another good episode um
i i
it's interesting how they make things
work because like the the whole thing
with them picking a fight at at the
water park felt like oh here we go this
is a repetitive beat
in like every season
this is very repetitive but
it's worth it for the uh conversational
outcomes that happen from it like when
you find out that they cheated with the
with the tube that hawk was floating on
on the slide that there was a hole in it
you see tories having a contemplation
about the fact that you know cheaters
cheaters and how you see that's
affecting her and also like you were
talking about the conversations
with um robbie trying to you know have a
more zen
piece of mind about this whole thing and
detaching himself from karate but still
feeling the attachment to certain
individuals there wanting to pull them
out of the multi-level marketing company
that is kobrik high
it's
trying to
trying to
[Music]
it's like it's hard to convince someone
when they are in that there's a time you
couldn't convince robbie to leave such a
such a thing you know so i don't think
he should be judgmental towards tory
about it in any way
um because there was definitely a time
where robbie himself wouldn't you
there's no talking to that man about it
and i
i do find miguel's aggression
fascinating because he gets so
aggressive it's the one it's the one
aspect where i'm like i feel like you
could maybe just talk
yeah both of you you got like so
aggressive with him at that one point
yeah but then again he's got a lot of
resentment towards him from
so much
painful history between the two kicked
him off the top of the thing and broke
his back man realized him almost not
that much yeah there's a lot of there's
so much pain between them and
i
i i i feel like
this season more than others like daniel
is so on edge
that he's just so blinded by everything
yeah and it's fascinating to watch
because
that whole thing at the charity thing
it's like you got to be a little bit
aware of what's what he's doing right
you got to be like you gotta be it's
that thing where he's just so
so anxiety fueled and so
on edge about this entire experience
that his hyper paranoia is making him
just like
searching for that validation that i
knew it he's doing something awful
and then he and but that's exactly what
his weak point is
to make him do the wrong maneuver
because yeah it was so obvious like from
not being in it that like come on you
know terry's lying to you about what he
said about amanda like you got to know
you you got to know but then you know
you put yourself in his shoes
and you go oh wait but this is very
human and uh and that tunnel vision you
get where you're like just do it say the
wrong thing say it okay now it's time to
flash out you know and uh that was
heartbreaking and good for amanda for
standing up for herself and just being
like she i mean i don't forget what she
had if i was her feeling like yeah this
relationship is awful these last four
years have been held this has been a
nightmare
dealing with some weird grudge
because it wasn't if it's not johnny
it's it's kyle um
uh not kyle
chris yeah kyle crease cat it's it's uh
it's crease and if it's not chris now
it's terry silver like there's always
going to be another person hillary swank
next season yeah jackie chan season
eight yeah
and then will comes in and smacks them
all yeah
get that producer credit earned um oh
yeah i thought this was i thought this
was a good episode um i'm not here to
rank any of the episodes but it was uh
every episode feels important but yeah
that that moment with johnny i thought
was especially was the most touching
part again it's that heart because we
haven't gotten any of johnny and danny
together at all like once and they don't
even like talk about each other
that'll be that'll be your big reunion i
bet yeah and especially after the way it
ended last season where they they saw
eye to eye and found respect for each
other
i'm surprised we haven't gotten any of
them together
you know
oh so it seems like johnny isn't very
much involved with cobra kai anything
right now no he's on his own personal
journey of finding himself a lot of this
for many characters seems to be about
finding themselves and i can't wait to
see chris too in prison
oh that's gonna be a big reintroduction
being someone's [ __ ] he's got he's
getting full sleeves yeah
he's getting whipped around man yeah
that's right tossed around the prison
game
anyway for cigarettes cobra kai episode
four done let's watch uh the next
episode now thanks for being here before
we go page
flev
doran levtavius doran
um
we've looked up your name on um
urban dictionary
here's what it says
an absolute legend off to a good start
with a massive hog
flav you're holding out on us i have hit
more definitions of the name flev
that's all there is yep that's it
it's decided i did not know you were
holding out on me so much man whip it
out phleb you're always leaving these
like very in-depth comments
and i'm like man this guy
protrudes such
glee and
just this sense of self-worth
and that he's better than everybody all
the time
it's massive hog energy it's massive hog
energy
so dude
how often you cook with that thing man
you know what i'm saying break me off a
piece of that bring enough piece of that
hog yeah wild hogs it's detachable from
my understanding mm-hmm well and then
all those comments are just what happens
when he like you know he rolls it out
and then it like hits the keyboard and
that's just what happens naturally i've
heard that he has created an ai for his
massive hog and that it types
automatically for him what he's really
thinking and feeling
on the inside underneath the surface
not the appropriate
you know politically correct side of
talking the truth he just goes with his
raw honest feelings as programmed by his
uh the algorithm because of his massive
hog
it's pretty the algorithm yeah it's it's
very impressive he's you fled lev
we are in awe of you if you could break
us off even a piece of that you know
just to kind of embellish our own
situations we would really appreciate it
look i've been asked to invest in
several tech companies and i'm telling
you i believe in the power of your
massive hogs i do too i will gladly
invest
hundreds of thousands of dollars i want
it on the ground floor into your massive
hog i think the technology of your
massive hog can revolutionize
the industry oh oh yeah we'll solve
world hunger we'll we'll fix the energy
crisis the war on drugs will be over you
know there'll be peace in every corner
of the world there's a lot your massive
hog can do for us man there's enough hog
to go around flev don't hold out and
frankly you're being kind of selfish
yeah that's rude so
i would it's cruel for love i don't let
the massive hog out of the pen you know
what i'm saying man
you know what i'm saying
[Music]
you